messieurs nous recevons ce soir sur le
plateau et cyril va arriver dans un
instant le numéro un mondial de paddle
a commencé le fantasia coillard parce
que y'a quoi ya deux ans et déjà il joue
avec le numéro un mondial des frères
bienvenus bienvenue roanne merci d'être
là alors vous étiez hier je crois un
gros tournoi jamais qu'on voit un point
exceptionnel c'était au moins pas de
retour et après on parle bien sûr pas
d'elle attendant que cyril décent
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu le poids il est allé chercher la
balle à l'extérieur du paddle comme vous
avez commencé pas donner ce que vous
faites du tennis avoue du squash
et
prévoit ma part elle doit commencer dès
cette année ça fait 20 ans que
je suis très reconnaissant
à content d'être ici en france et je
vois que le panel atteint un niveau très
haut ici ah oui alors forcément c'est
sûr évident comme on joue il n'est pas
là encore comme on joue serré la
main
oui quelles sont les qualités de celui
qu'on appelle l'animal en france
et
vous aimiez pays redevienne
la
gestapo france
jeunes et palisson est largué la fina et
c'est quand même moins vienne et la tour
eiffel
il avait là que
j'ai vu qu'il a un super niveau il a un
super niveau alors adrien vous avez
affronté donc cyril en fin d olive et le
numéro un mondial c'est la première fois
qu'un espagnol d'ailleurs est classé
numéro 1 d'avancé désert les argentins
qui avaient une 2 1 voilà alors on a les
images de la rencontre d'abord quoique
c'est l'échauffement me semble-t-il
c'était aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui cet après midi
[Musique]
aucune
exception
[Rires]
alors
si
c'est ça ne clique pas les belles
joies calcio
[Musique]
je commence à 4 c au chili
est arrivé en costume trois pièces et et
comment ces jo font aussi bien je ne
sais pas en tant qu elles sont donc ça
c'était l'échauffement on a d'autres
images regardez je vous dirai évidemment
quelle a été l'issue du match entre
cyril parentaux série le contre vous
avec le numéro mondial pour sa part me
regarde
[Musique]
en amour il s'arrête avant c'était ok
peut jouer comme lui quand j'ai sa
raquette
like you
are et j'allais commencer par l'espagne
au
volant met une tannée et meilleur
français contre les meilleurs espagnols
et le meilleur de tunisie
vers man down to win non non c'est celle
on n'est pas sûrs en effet comme au
tennis et ça de cet ios et le même score
qu'à el tenine bareil et en cas
d'égalité il ya un super tie-break
soleil au super tie break où partent
avec et hyundai d'accord très bien au
sein des cellules oh mais est bien sûr
et qu'on ne voit pas le dire tout de
suite là on voit pas tout et donner le
résultat du match quand vous expliquer
que le paddle comme ça prenne un essor
partout en france même en europe en même
temps monde qu'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les gens se mettent au
paddle est elle pas les stats et
nintendo prépare pour massy commenter et
de la personne à qui elle est en
pratiquant une enquête a bien sûr des
portes est moins facile et pratique
arnaud il avait attaqué tôt dans le
médical recommencer un prêt royal pas
elle est gâtée chez alcatel location à
l'aube médico-sociaux glauque et qui a
partagé ses portes et vous social 4 est
simple
et celle pas l image n ai
reçu des petits bouts
si on en fait en résumé tout le monde
peut y jouer une tige social que tout le
monde peut jouer qu'on s'amuse c'est
vito pas 2 euros comme en voilà et c'est
la vraie différence est au tennis parce
que s'évade rien quand on pense au
tennis avant de se marrer et de faire un
bel échange et va se passer un peu de
temps à il faut commencer par prendre
des cours pour se perfectionner alors
qu'au pad alms en cours on peut
commencer à se débrouiller à mettre la
balle dedans et il ya vraiment s'amuser
et comme correspond à la bourre il est
en face de nous mais est ce que ça vous
est imposé d'avoir le numéro un mondial
est ce que c'est vraiment impressionnant
assez exceptionnel il est il est un coup
trois crans au dessus nous les meilleurs
français le 3 quand que trois crans vous
même voire cinq mais ils ont ils ont ils
à une générale ils ont laissé les
espagnols en une génération d'écart ils
ont commencé le paddle nous on était des
joueurs de tennis qui se sont mis au pas
d'elle donc c'est vrai que ça fait une
énorme une énorme différence et dans
tous les secteurs du jeu il est bien au
dessus de nous après ils épient les
numéros un mondiales aussi donc donc ça
c'est normal qu'ils jouent aussi bien
mais en tout cas nous français les
meilleurs français on est vraiment très
loin de son niveau
roanne c'est quoi les grands grands
tournois aujourd'hui ce quart
l'équivalent d'un windows and à roland
garros ouais comme un coma grand chelem
à pareille
à del avancé prendre un essor comme
elles viennent de dire et on toute
franchise nous allons venir
deux fois face à toulouse d'abord
je vous anime
je vous
inviterai intéressant je répète traça
france allait pas d'elle se développe
nous avons besoin
il délire des sept générations que le
padel prenne de l'essor et je pense que
la france aille rivaux très bien et je
vous félicite je félicite l'équipe
française
nous ont pas de moi mais je suis je suis
le goût bien sûr je m'étais pas
d'ailleurs c'est important qu'on fait
tous au paddle je crois que vous voulez
mode fadul vous avez sirigu bien sûr
je suis très très bon
il faut le dire il faut ni
cette rencontre c'est pas ça vous fait
grâce à vous c'est vous qui a fait venir
c'est grâce surtout à ma femme ah oui
vraiment fait un petit espagnol
me sotomayor et
connaissez et roiné et toute son équipe
et aussi grâce à toi parce qu'on avait
parlé il ya trois mois et j'ai enfin
finalisé à ce que roanne vienne après
bruxelles où il a gagné évidemment le
tournoi après
venir venez est un phénomène venir à
paris pour affronter la lima bien sûr
évident alors je vous le dis c'est comme
si nadal a non suitées toi tu te plaît
c'est comme si on tennis on recevait
rafael nadal c'est comme si en natation
recevait michael phelps c'est comme si
on television brevets
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous en dis tu veux que tout le monde
se lève ah bah oui c'est le numéro un
mondial et nos légendes
et comme matthias rath où il fera bon à
savoir vraiment
il a pas reçues si césar non plus ça va
sans déconner jamais la pression on est
tous un peu d'histoire des césars
séraphine élégant fait il remercie des
gens tu tombes à l'istec mutel frousse à
bas
un costume qui a fait un travail
exceptionnel
bernard c'est également la lumière
clément susman au beach
isabelle beat uni
[Rires]
oui
ça me donne ça mais je voulais bien
alors adrien maigret
je te le dis j'ai fait une exception
puisque d'habitude je joue toujours un
cadre et un c'est mon partenaire je suis
jalouse et smile partner
tu apprends beaucoup de lui c'est vrai
en volume il apprend également beaucoup
de monde
c'est pas parce que tu viens d'espagne
sont toutes hors éléments non
par des fans de tout âge il a raison et
une humanité un croix vous la jouer
ensemble tu vois il me laissait faire ce
que je voulais même fait à démerder tout
c'est incroyable je voudrais remercier
mon ami tony le corse ça c'est moi
les fihri j'ai pas trop suivi parce
qu'il y avait décidé d'aller là bas
c'est à pas mal c'est une photo oui mais
là quand même oui mais pour moi elle est
là pour nous aller sera toujours les
bravos
la femme de tony et aussi te plaît eux
qui n'ont pas de commencer
[Rires]
le panneau lettonie l'amérique bien sûr
ni la mairie mme harel épistolaire tony
la mairie
en espagnol mais
les
gars merci bon c'est pas une seule
mairie arrête de me regarder comme ça
hein bah oui c'est la femme à tony
la femme à tony
il
est arrivé sports s'était
endormi voir ta vie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tony
se dire qu'est ce que je vois
quatre reprises
je vais bientôt venir en madriers la
femme à tony non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
blancs ça
s'appelle comment est mis sur ton
maillot et 10 ottomane
[Applaudissements]
ap
c'est pourquoi un cadeau pourquoi
m'invite à mme habib pour dans quelques
fins ouais mais tu joues pas bien tu
verras bien surprise surprise oui oui
tu verras n'assurent pas leur
cadeau
des fruits tendresse pour que tu en
profites moi même fait deux séjours
non ça c'est lui qui me touche rire mais
c'est ma grosse amato nous
[Rires]
côtoyons pour l'été comme celle de
champion du maurier par la passe et le
maillot de champion du monde
c'est l'attentisme mais a soutenu amadou
sall et quand je vais mettre panchir est
amazigh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Rires]
se balade n'est pas séparé un éclair de
génie là
attention à l'eau cela doit non ça va on
l'a vu
est ce que c'est pas vous angoisse à
jouer alors retourné
on n'avait pas souffert des voix
regardez là bas et vous faites
maintenant les jaunes sur la femme a
deux de ces partis ne regardez pas mon
papa c'est quoi on ne peut pas pour toi
légers devront tenter toujours on peut
travailler
maintenant qu'ils se taisent
hypocrite c'est vrai moi j'adore elle a
raison et appauvrissant j'aimerais pas
voilà fully n'arriverait pas qu'il fasse
à madrid ou bien d'aller une femme ça va
ça lui antoine sa
forme cinq sens la vue comme je connais
le public mardi elle est comme échelle
docteur de là les joueurs de monaco il
connaît ses supporters
auxquels il retourne toi bien que tu
vois pas du tout le pas cyril certaines
émotions demain tu en entraînement et en
force et en forme
tcm octobre le spa nom est monstrueux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
anémone j'ai vraiment c'est que lui je
suis comme un fou c'est un amour nommé
et c'est une bombe il faut il faut le
dire à rien si c'est une longue à wayss
& légendes et il fait que faire évoluer
le sport de ces tournois en tournois
c'est impressionnant et il est tellement
gentil tout est vraiment un amour
éthique tu remercieras oui et j'ai
invité à roland garros a déclenché chez
pas mal de terrain comme
[Rires]
dans les banlieues
tu m'a vidé mes parents je serai là
après on dit c'est un match un petit
j'ai un métier quand même mais je serai
là t'inquiète pas c'est ma passion prend
parfois le pas son métier mais jamais
tu prêt à venir je suis prévenir mais je
suis à deux pas et d'aller y aller quand
même manqué par
et pour jouer avec without you
are est lebron et à un bail si tu vas
faire pas moi je vais le faire je vais
j'ai demandé une invitation pour dans le
tableau final c'est vrai dans le tableau
final et on peut pas faire les qualifs
de ses 10 ans si elle est qualifiée
avoir des points du circuit fip donc
pour moi ça coûte
[Rires]
je me dis pas comment dire gardien fois
malheureusement savait difficile un prêt
bancaire laisse essayer non mais je vais
passer j'ai passé une tête au ras
j'espère que tu peux pas l'avoir
impressionnante qui peut venir jouer
parce que les taux moyens
impressionnants il ya aussi repris
préalable incroyable si tu ton courage
impressionnent mondiale a je sais rien
merci de remuer le couteau dans la plaie
mais j'adore alors on est ici on m'a
cassé mon métier ou parce que alors j'en
ai fait un match d'après le jour n'était
justement à la fin mars a prévenu josé
celui qui avait lebron numéro un mondial
avec moi numéro 1 de tout dire bah et la
poutre
la côte des basques d'accord contre
adrien maigri le numéro 5 français est
thomas mitjana numéro 20 voilà donc
c'était gratin français et demi contre
le gratin international frère vous vous
êtes les graviers dans le gratin
gratin français entre le gratin et le
tajine internationale
cette femme enceinte alors on va voir
apparemment le million les matches à
l'image du match oui absolument t'as
déjà vu un gars dans une autre émission
qui donne à son papa
[Rires]
là tu sais que tu vois un gars est
encore temps d'agir ya deux semaines
le gars il a pris la côte on les a
on est où là sans déconner et les gars
tu sais ça présente aujourd'hui ça
bordel de merde
je sais comment je faisais sauf autres
avec mes buts c'est
alexandre guerrier n'y est trop vieux
ils échouent mais
alexandre pas pas dirigé toujours j'ai
jeté jamais manqué de respect wendel
j'étais toujours d'une bourgeoisie
encore incroyable avec moi le gars on
les a
regardés 102 minutes oh ça va moi
j'arrive je suis tout émoustillé noire
tony le champion du monde adrien joie
des gens que je n'ai pas vu depuis
longtemps
tue tout content de les voir et l'hôtel
j'ai mal à son frère
ressaisis toi ben il ya l'image il est à
l'image et yappa et dans d'autres
émissions ne fait pas mais dans d'autres
émissions les animateurs ils ont une
oreillette en outre
[Rires]
je vais pas l'orientation ils ont rien
dit rien à me dire ils ont à venir
quand et comment ça coûte cette petite
merveille cinquante mille euros 6 avec
un peu notre mini série encore sans
bruit
[Applaudissements]
génial
c'est chez plon riad jeu de lorient
lauriad chez de lorient la mollesse et
mais c'est bon là que le guet robinet
mais c est là qu à l achat de colas l
ensemble du système non mari
benjamin qu'est-ce qui a ça va ça coûte
alors c'est quoi c'est bien pour savoir
bon d'accord vous voulez pas vous dire
combien cette même
s'il vous plaît ce sens bien s'il vous
plaît
alors l'autre mais nourdine fait j'en ai
fait que et si tu nourris y est à plus
de nilo
[Rires]
voilà servi sous la halle couverte vous
la mettez sur le bon coin de l'armée
après témoin tout le couvercle et oum
été clamé service juste jamais été faut
dire qu'elle était deux fois dont plus
sûres
c'est pas par là qu'on attend
détrompez vous voilà donc merci voilà
donc çà çà çà çà part ça s'est joué à la
main et je peux payer directement à ma
personne mien
bon alors ça c'est ça la fiche c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
que nous n'avons
donc ça
ça c'est ça c'est ça voilà ce qu'on veut
mais voilà ce qu'on me donne les noms
mais là c'est 30 minutes a tenu axe
oui l équipe est menée l'année lotim
angel lotina de lézards et c'est quoi ça
nota peux pas me voir faire des pas dit
dullas sans déconner c'est ça c'est ça
ce que ça représente hanouna bon ça
marche on tenait au massacre de
confiance en poussant à rejoindre rien
à un moment je vous serai seul au bac il
face à votre copine hanouna il sera pas
toujours là voilà les mots qui m'ont
donné regardes ses données mais regardez
ce qu'ils m'ont donné
votre animateur tu dis voilà alors
quel animateur ces trente minutes sur du
paddle bah ouais mais c'est parce que
j'ai envie d'intéresser les gens à tout
l'espace est bien à la raison et à vous
aussi je fais le parfois une demi-heure
sur vous plaît restez les gens s'en
foutent
d'après vous déclarez joueurs d'honneur
du paddle pas tous d'accord tout ce que
vous faites nero c'est énorme
nous on a découvert sa grâce à vous je
vois sans arrêt maintenant pas de le
tirer de là par toi surtout si vous
faites une communication c'est parce que
je finisse truc de panneaux après je
pars directement j'ai une animation à
verser ou non tamponneuses ce que j'ai
je
relance la tanzanie marc dutroux j'anime
également un stand au togo nous y voilà
mais la fille non mais bernard a raison
je devrais avoir un petit ya pas de
médaille et un truc bah ouais y'a pas de
massy nantis trafic en tous cas on a
pratiquement la nation française de
presse ils sont très sympas avec moi la
fédé oui
parce que s'ils gagnent pas faut donner
donner quelque chose que je dois changer
mon portable
jouer le tournoi paix 2000 quelques
temps et je fais là toi je fais les
qualifs à la semaine prochaine et la
semaine prochaine à perpignan il est en
qualifs ils n'ont pas donné la deuxième
le card mais je suis en qualifs mais été
on a le charme au classement grâce à
notre classement nous a carrément voilà
exactement c'est quoi la wet carte
invités finalisation une habitation et
par land allemand toit
d'une invitation cartes d'invitation à
la wild card une fois et tout le monde
aura la carte ce jour là bas tout le
monde aura la carte ce jour la
fesci alors oui non mais où iront
directement dans le tableau final
bientôt grâce à leur classement mais
pourquoi voulons pas donner à cette
invitation aie aie ça suffit qu'on va
savoir d'invitation moi je comprends
tout à fait moi je veux faire les
qualifs maintenant c'est pas fini
maintenant on n'avait pas ce qui va avec
notre classement peut-être qu'on peut
rentrer en table finale si un
désistement
ça peut arriver à tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
que vous vous entraîniez un peu moi je
pense
[Rires]
ils ont bien on aura tout vu alors que
des possibilités dans
le titre parce que je disais
[Applaudissements]
la face à la côte et toi pour des
tortillas
et là tu voudras
j'ai des fois je te la presse en espagne
jean v ou le tout la côte
amalfitaine
on a enquêté avec valérie et adrien nous
faisait qu'à partir de demain vous
commencé un entraînement physique
spécifique up paddle ouais ça sèche
demain il et il a l'air d'être très en
tout cas mentalement je n'allais
l'annoncé le directement voilà ça va
être un moment très spécifique très
intensif parce que c'est la grosse marge
de progression ça va être aussi sur
l'intensité physique et
la capacité ça c'est une évidence et il
a beaucoup de progrès à faire
techniquement donc le niveau qu'il a
aujourd'hui avec le sens faire
d'entraînement est déjà très bon donc
avec de l'entraînement je pense qu'il
peut viser son objectif d'être absente
un autre il ya un autre
directive il arrêter cette caméra cachée
[Applaudissements]
tout on voit que tu as de la magie tu as
du talent
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on peut dire ce qu'il a dit ou
l'ama
non moi j'avais une question si
si vous vous entraînez un peu plus vous
aurez pas besoin d'invitation
beauté si vous n'aimez pas qu'ils jouent
alors y'a quoi on doit voir
alors qui a gagné regardez c'est le
premier set regarde le premier
jusqu'à
et
non
on sait green day
et tient la baraque parce que là ils
étaient des professionnels et tient la
barre des 10 mois là c'est comme si je
jouais avec nadal et djokovic logiciel
et non et non parce qu'il fait cyril là
dia
a même
son poids
est
which is tu sais
m'ont mis au frigo à
toucher une balle
est-ce que tu étais les ondes dans le
couple des amis le smat qui fait la
passe et enfin appris sa voix les deux
il nous a donné une petite séance
d'entraînement à la fin du match pour
nous expliquer comment bien ce match et
c'est une de ces grosses qualités assez
rien et c'est assez impressionnant vente
bravo alors et vous demandez qui a gagné
ah bah oui
cache pas qu'il n'aurait pas mis les
images
[Rires]
partir a ajouté
terry est adrien énorme joueur non non
on va pendre alors on a gagné voilà on
vous dit on a gagné à 11,9 au super tie
prêté à l'aca on peut voir un peu c'est
bien la balle et
[Musique]
maman tu la vis
pourtant il est là il
faut mettre en évidence la performance
de cyril aujourd'hui bien fait un mail
au frigo
et m'a mis au frigo c'est dur mais ils
m'ont mis au frigo avais tu veux trop
bien officiellement mis au frigo un
petit peu mais mon but au frigo j'ai dit
qu'il y ait mon vieux frigo comme au
meilleur prix au nom de la mère fois de
ma vie que je le vois jouer
je me suis pas aperçu entre le
professionnel jean monnet mois les
séries comme à passer le bac 10 ans
c'est comme si tu joues avec moi avec
benzema
parfois lebron est donc champion merci
monde adrien d'être là c'est toujours
demain on s'entraîne matteau toi 6h
10h 11h30
10h30 à 11h30 on met d'abord moi je
m'entraîne à fond et la région
spécifique mary d'alimentation cbnm qui
a écrit deux régions
vous l'êtes boulettes et au niveau de
l'hygiène de vie ces crédits vont vous
dire que mon ami je n'ai pas de
champions contre
l'as s'est couché 5 heures du matin
lever 16 heures et agit en otage une
taxe
carbone ne trouve à main on mange
ensemble oui j'ai surveillé ce que tu
manges et fortes températures demain
c'est vrai
ici et dans ton slip